[Musique]
j'ai eu l'opportunité de candidater au
programme qu'est-ce qu'il a un programme
d'excellence intelligence artificielle
qui avait pour but de mettre en lumière
les talents cachés dans les quartiers
comme le mien à trappe j'ai rencontré
mes quatre autres camarades avec
lesquels nous avons développé c'est du
propre une application de reconnaissance
des déchets qui sert aussi bien aux
citoyens qu' aux agents en mairie et aux
agents d'entretien on a pu présenter
notre solution au salon vivateek où
là-bas on a remporté la première place
de ce programme parmi 22 projets et on
s'envo en mars donc pour la silicone
vallleée à la quête de nouveaux horizons
et encore s'ouvrir l'esprit découvrir de
nouvelles technologies j'ai adoré cette
expérience d'entreprendre dans notre
propre projet en développant nous-même
de A à Z et ça m'a fait un déclic
quelques mois plus tard et j'ai décidé
de concilier ces mes compétences avec
mes ambitions en créant
SK
à travers différentes intelligences
artificielles qu'on a pu créer skio
offre une plateforme personnalisée sur
mesure et à la demande à n'importe quel
étudiant par exemple s'il a une question
sur un cours qu'il a vu en classe notrea
lui offre une nouvelle explication avec
des diaporamas et une voix comme s'il
était en
classe on est super content pour CEIO ça
se développe petit à petit actuellement
on est basé à la station EF on vient de
signer nos deux premiers stagiaires on
continue sans C de se développer sur un
plan plus personnel je suis développeur
actuellement pour une start-up orientée
énergie verte pour lequel on prépare un
projet que on va présenter au CES Las
Vegas en janvier donc encore une
expérience folle et inoubliable et on
prépare forcément le le voyage de mars
pour la silicone vallée avec le
programme qu'est-ce qu'il y
a apprendre c'est déchiffrer l'inconnu
ouvrir l'impossible acquérir de
nouvelles compétences c'est svrir de
nouveaux horizons et la vie a toujours
plus d'imagination que
[Musique]
nous